did dr. Wallach I've got a
three-year-old daughter that is just
three years old as of last month she was
diagnosed on a pediatric ophthalmologist
with it's a trophy ax her right eyes
turning in they prescribed some strong
glasses for three or four months and
then it seemed fairly commonplace in the
explanation that they would pretty
quickly
uh sure her into surgery to get it
corrected if the glasses did not
self-correct wanted to get your input on
what uh what happened we should be
exploring okay you can actually go
online there's I exercise that can
actually help that type of issue
okay without surgery and you can do
these things yourself
certainly I can interfere with anything
that doctors are gonna do the glasses I
go ahead and get the glasses and but
also go online and look that up
non-surgical therapy and you'll find
that there's a little I exercise you can
do these go way back and they're still
they still work and then of course I was
his child way roughly thirty pounds
she's she's in the light or something
okay does she have any eggs or
dermatitis she does not any asthma
bronchitis no challenges there okay
about poems none okay good all right
sure what stubble in program when you
give this 30 pound child for she's got
some muscle problems eye muscle problems
what's up well a healthy brain and her
pecs but but she does only needs a third
surdo yeah yeah one healthy brain a
heart pakka lasts for three months and
so the thing to do is to mix up one dose
and then you know put it in something
like a baby bottle which measures ounces
or something so you can give her a third
of that dose and of that third you're
gonna give her I'd break that in half so
you're gonna give her a sixth of a dose
of breakfast at dinner time right you
divide that third into a half half of em
and third and breakfast in their time
and what else would you give her as far
as there's one piece missing if you just
give the healthy brain and heart attack
um gluco gel well no you got to get the
EFA s which are in this healthy
perfect but I puncture those things in
this court in your mouth you know I'd
give her yeah I'd go ahead and give her
one of the EF A's and one of the FA plus
sedation have the FA at breakfast
they've made plus a dinner time function
squirt on your mouth or in the
supplements that's kind of what I would
do and get those exercises and then call
us in two weeks and four weeks or six
weeks